Google cloud workflows is a service to
help you more easily connect and chain
together other services including Google
cloud services your own custom services
and external third-party services into
Solutions
and now thanks to parallel steps you can
speed up your workflow executions but
first how can workflows help you you can
create complex workflows like Advanced
data processing jobs multi-step service
orchestration or automated Cloud
resource provisioning with ease
workflows also make it easy to connect
other Google cloud services with a
library of connectors that handle
authentication and formatting of
requests for you so you can focus on
what's important running your jobs on a
scalable serverless backend thanks to
all this workflows is an ideal solution
for gluing together services like
bigquery and Cloud run to build
processing pipelines for data Media or
machine learning jobs
or you could automate common platform
operations processes and have them
trigger based on a schedule manual
action or from an event
each step of a workflow is executed
sequentially so you can build full
reliable applications or build modular
jobs and integrate them into larger
systems
but what happens when your workflow has
steps that might take a while to execute
like multiple long-running queries
normally each step will wait for the
previous one to complete even if the
current step doesn't depend on the
previous step when running multiple
independent queries you probably don't
want each query to block execution
thanks to the new parallel steps feature
you can speed things up and run steps at
the same time you can build your
workflows and Define which steps are
parallel so those steps can be run
without blocking execution
using parallel steps can help to
decrease the overall time it takes to
run your workflows
let's show you exactly how parallel
steps can help you speed up the
execution of multiple long-running
operations by walking through a sample
we'll start with a workflow that
executes multiple queries on Wikipedia
data and see how long that takes then
we'll update the workflows to use
parallel steps and see the difference
in this example our workflow will query
five different Wikipedia tables to find
the most popular pages
we can use bigquery sample data sets to
access the information from Wikipedia
each table in a data set represents a
different month and we can run a simple
bigquery job on each table to find the
most popular pages from that month
we'll start with a workflow that
executes the steps sequentially here's
the code from workflows that shows how
the tables are queried first we'll
declare the tables that we want to query
against the init step as well as the
results variable that will hold the
results from the queries
in the Run query step we'll Loop over
the tables and query each one for the
pages with the most views
query takes about 20 seconds to complete
after the query is run we'll grab the
top results from each table and add it
to the results variable
check out the link in the description to
a code lab that has access to the full
code so you can try it out for yourself
running this workflow gives us data we
were looking for looks like each month
had the same top page with page views in
the millions but because each query was
run sequentially it took around 100
seconds since each query had to wait for
the previous query to complete before
starting the whole workflow takes as
long to run as each query combined now
let's convert this same workflow to use
parallel steps and see how long it takes
adding parallel steps couldn't be easier
in fact we just need to place the for
Loop inside a parallel step in addition
we'll declare the results variable as a
shared variable so each query can store
the results in the shared variable
creating a shared variable ensures all
assignments are Atomic so you don't need
to worry about race conditions or which
order the jobs are executed in all you
need to do is declare a variable as
shared and workflows will handle the
rest
now when we run our workflow with
parallel steps we get our results in the
same time it takes to run a single step
20 seconds
running steps in parallel can speed up
any workflows that have long running
steps which needlessly block other steps
from executing or when you have multiple
branches that can be run in isolation
to try parallel steps in Cloud workflows
out for yourself check out the code lab
in the description you can also learn
more by visiting the documentation happy
workflowing
[Music]